why hello there
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report direct message for march
10 2021 and i want to welcome you to the
show
whether you've been cancelled or you
haven't been cancelled or you're about
to be cancelled
you're welcome here on the reuben
i'm on the reuben report on the reuben
report before we get to it guys
wait i need a little drink man
i do a lot of talking throughout the day
uh before we get to it guys uh click
that subscribe
button and that notification bell to
make sure that you have a chance to see
in our videos and
we are doing something very rare today i
think this actually might be a first
this might actually be a first as you
know i like to do three stories because
i don't want to overload you
sometimes i say we'll do four stories
today but today
we're going to do five stories we're
actually doing five stories we're going
to talk about this
absolutely ridiculous apology that one
of the band members of
mumford and sons issued yesterday
because he
read this very scary book from my friend
andy no and as you know
andy noe is a very very dangerous scary
guy so we're going to talk about that
then we're going to talk about this
giant evil corporation you might have
heard of them
you might even watch some of their
movies have some of their products the
disney
corporation they're up to no good oh and
then uh story number three
columbia university which was once a
place
that was highly esteemed in a place of
higher education and a place that
was thought of as like one of the primo
places to go to really learn something
in the world
well they're having segregated
graduations so we're going to
break down those segregated graduations
and then the fourth story today is this
fouchy guy you know the infallible
fouchy uh he's kind of admitting they
don't have science anymore and they've
sort of
lost the thing and they're not sure what
they're gonna do but they're just gonna
keep telling you what to do even though
they don't know what they're doing oh
and five
joy reads she's a host on msnbc i hope
you don't watch msnbc nothing good is
happening over there
uh she's a racist so we're gonna get to
all of that uh but before we do i wanna
talk to you fine people
about built a bar you know spring is in
the air and you know what that means
people
swimsuit season is just around the
corner you might be thinking i know dave
but how can i
tame my sweet tooth well don't fret
people i've got just the solution for
you
built bar is the secret to eating
healthier food while also eating tastier
food
built bars are low calorie low sugar
high protein high fiber
great for the keto diet i can actually
lose or maintain weight while indulging
in a yummy treat
healthy has never been this delicious
build bars taste like candy and come in
18 amazing flavors including mint
brownie and cherry barcia you guys know
that my
personal favorite is the cookies and
cream though bars are covered in
a hundred percent chocolate include both
nut and nut
free flavors and are soft and easy to
chew i know with restaurants finally
opening up
almost here in california it'll be
tempting to indulge but we also need to
shed those additional quarantine pounds
which is why built bars are the perfect
alternative to pie for the health
conscious guy
each bar contains 110 to 160 calories 16
to 20 grams of protein
three to five net carbs you don't need
the luck of the irish or a pot of gold
to buy a built bar
go to builtbar.com and use promo code
ruben to get 20 off your next order use
promo code ruben for 20
off at builtbar.com and now back to me
i'm going to sip a little water
oh you know i wasn't planning on doing
this but before anything else you know i
went into the
to the youtube comment section there
yesterday and a few of you noted
that when i asked michael yesterday
about on the fly
because we were doing it on the fly how
much does a new york times subscription
cost
there was a little bit of confusion i
thought he was saying eight dollars a
week
and then you know there's four weeks in
a month that's going to get you to
you know roughly 36 bucks something like
that and then
i multiplied that over the course of the
year i said it was going to be about 400
a year it looks like it's somewhere
between 96 and 104 dollars but
i am happy to report that uh you guys
fact checked us on this
and i have no problem addressing that
you're all math and magicians and we're
very proud of you and i can confirm that
a squared
plus b squared equals c squared all
right guys story number one
uh so mumford and sons you know these
guys uh they're a band they're playing
the music
great you like them you don't like them
doesn't really matter people people like
them
uh well one of the mumford and sons
guitarists
uh he is now leaving the band because he
supported andy noe now if you don't know
andy now i think most of you know andy
know andy noah is an actual journalist
notice my hands were clasped when i said
journalist and usually when i say
journalist i have to go like this
andy noah is an actual journalist who
i've had the pleasure of getting to know
over the last
couple years i've seen him out in the
field he has interviewed me
i've interviewed him i found him to be
curious and decent
and and demure and nice and pleasant and
all this stuff he's gotten himself into
a lot of controversies because he's
dared to cover antifa
honestly and uh they don't like being
covered honestly and then
this leftist media obviously doesn't
like it when someone's actually doing
the work that they're supposed to be
doing
so in any event uh andy wrote this book
unmasked i interviewed for him for it a
couple weeks ago so you can catch that
on the
youtube right here and it's a very scary
book it's a scary book okay and you
could hit someone over the head with it
and hurt them
uh well winston marshall the guitarist
from mumford and sons he
tweeted this it's uh quite fascinating
he said congratulations mr
andy know finally had time to read your
important book
you're a brave man okay so he
read a book a guitarist for a popular
band read a book and then
congratulated the author this is a book
that's
you know been published by legit people
and you know
got good names on the back tucker
carlson douglas murray ayan hersey ali
pretty
pretty impressive uh i'm gonna guess
that winston marshall here doesn't agree
with absolutely everything
perhaps that's in the book or certainly
that andy noe believes they're probably
different independent people but all he
said was congrats
on the book and you're a brave man
you've tackled a difficult topic that
that
in essence is what he's saying that
whether you agree with andy or not
on everything whether you agree that
antifa is a domestic terrorist
organization
as i believe if you believe or whether
you believe that's
that's an overstatement it's pretty
brave to write a book like this i think
we
i think most of us would agree with that
well you're not going to believe this he
sends that tweet out and then the mob
does what the mob does and the mob went
after him
and then winston marshall and let me be
clear about this i had no idea who
winston marshall was before this
if i'm not mistaken he has less than ten
thousand followers but obviously mumford
and son is is a big band but he did
exactly
what you cannot do
in the face of the mob and that is
bend the knee you cannot apologize if
you have nothing to apologize
for that does not mean you can never
apologize if
you feel authentically that you've done
something worthy of an apology then give
that apology
i apologize in my private life and i've
apologized publicly
before for things so if it's earnest and
honest
then an apology is good i think we all
know that but because an
amorphous largely anonymous twitter mob
attacks you you cannot
apologize and we know that nothing good
will come out of it
however winston marshall he did it and
here's uh here's his statement
over the past few days i have come to
better understand the pain
caused by the book i endorsed i have
offended not only a lot of people i
don't know but also those
closest to me including my bandmates and
for that i am truly sorry
as a result of my actions i am taking
time away from the band to examine my
blind spots
for now please know that i realize how
my endorsements have the potential to be
viewed as approvals
of hateful divisive behavior i apologize
as this
was not at all my intention winston
marshall
you're a [ __ ] uh i get the inclination
i get it it's not fun when people say
mean things to you on twitter you're not
going to believe this but not everyone
loves me
and sometimes people say mean thing mean
things to me on twitter you can mute
them you can block them you can ignore
them those are those are options um
but first off what's what's very bizarre
here is he says this thing about
uh what's i want to get the exact line
here uh the
the pain caused by the book i endorsed
now as far as i could tell he'd never
endorsed whatever that means like a
banned
member endorsing i don't even know what
that would mean but he didn't endorse it
he said congratulations
finally a time to read your important
book you're a brave man
all right i mean i guess that's some
sort of a tacit endorsement
at some level but he's going to step
away from the ban
and he's offended the band mates and the
approval of hateful divisive behavior
have you ever heard anything come out of
andy nose mouth that is hateful or
divisive
he's writing a book about the hateful
and divisive people
up is down left is right war is peace
you guys get it yet this is such
pathetic
it's such acquiescence it's such oh i'll
feed the alligators so the alligator
won't get me well
you're just nothing now and i guess you
know you'll just dip out for a little
while and then maybe you'll come back to
the band
but you'll be half a man you'll be half
a broken man
and i you know just for you guys out
there
just never apologize if it's not
legit nothing that he said there for now
please know that i realize how my
endorsements have the potential to be
viewed
as approvals of hateful divisive
behavior
yeah no that's not this i hope you guys
get it i think you get it
but if you think if you think that's
ridiculous like band members
bands popular bands breaking up in
essence
because one of them liked a certain book
that's against the hateful organizations
if you think that's stupid
well this is a really interesting story
because this broke
so this what i'm about to tell you
actually happened back in october of
2020
but it wasn't reported on until the last
couple days because of all this
stupidity
with uh mr potato head and all the dr
seuss books and everything else we've
got a quote here from the new york
post uh children under seven will be
forbidden from watching
dumbo peter pan's swiss family robinson
and the aristocrats
settings on the app will prevent the
movies from even showing up on the young
viewers profile so what they're
referring to there is
uh disney plus disney plus when you sign
in
in essence and i'm sure you guys have
seen this on uh you know on netflix or
on hulu on some of the other ones
you know you have your adult profile and
then there's like a children's
profile right that way i guess if you're
not with the kids you can just blog them
into the kid thing and then they're
going to just get kid movies they're not
going to you know see
all the rest of the adult trash that's
on those sites i have no problem with
that by the way and most people don't
what's strange about what disney has
done here is they've taken
these specific movies dumbo which i'm
pretty sure is a kids movie
peter pan swiss family robinson and the
aristocrats they will no longer be in
the kids section those are now going to
be
for adults which is very bizarre but the
walt disney company issued a statement
about this they said these stereotypes
were wrong then and are wrong now
rather than remove this content we want
to acknowledge its harmful impact
learn from it and spark conversation to
create a more
inclusive future together all right so
just to be very clear here
dumbo peter pan swiss family robinson
and the aristocrats
no one has ever been hurt by these
movies no one has ever been hurt they do
not further
racism uh or have tastes
changed over the years has what the
overton window accepts change over the
years
yes is some of that okay and is some of
that progress
at some level yes the answer is yes to
that
but if you think that these things have
uh
put forth bad ideas that have really
hurt people
no one i mean simply nobody has been
hurt by these things but they're
pretending
that they have and well let's show you
some images from some of these things
because they have the specific images
that are the scary images
here this is from dumbo and i remember
dumbo watching as a kid
i thought these so these crows
apparently are racist now
i always thought of them as crows i just
thought they were a bunch of snarky
funny crows that hung out together and
they kind of talked fast
and you know that was it but apparently
the portrayal
of the crows in 1941's dumbo uh
is is racist at some level uh peter pan
as you can see here now
there's a what appears to be an indian
chief smoking the peace pipe now as far
as i know indian chiefs in the past
did smoke peace pipes they might even
still today but that
is being criticized over its depiction
of native americans you might
think that well that's interesting
because he wasn't a bad guy in the movie
and you know
peter if i'm not mistaken kind of liked
what he was seeing there and maybe it
got people to understand
native american culture a little bit
more but you know call me crazy i don't
know
this is swiss family robinson uh this
was flagged for portraying the pirates
as a foreign
menace because you know you don't want
to offend pirates
in 2021 so the best thing that you can
do is get rid of movies from about 60
years ago
unclear to me what he's doing to this
woman at the moment she doesn't look
thrilled to be there so maybe there's
some legitimacy to this one
i'll give you that and then the
aristocrats which is one of my favorite
disney movies from 1970 it includes
problematic stereotypes of asian culture
and yes is there a cat
using chopsticks to play the piano there
is
there is and if you think that that
caused anyone to hate asian people
you're an idiot
and again tastes change over the years
our feelings and the way we look at art
changes over the years
there are things that are happening
right now in 2021
that the progressives of 2040 will end
up canceling themselves
they will actually cancel themselves if
you don't think that eventually they'll
come for everything else
whatever it is if you're watching this
and you grew up in the 80s or 90s and
you loved
seinfeld or you loved what what
the simpsons whatever it is that you
loved they will
come for that too so look disney is
just to be clear because i can already
hear what people are going to say disney
has every right to categorize their
movies wherever they want if they really
felt though
that this was racist stuff they would be
getting rid of it right because that's
what we do we
we get rid of things but now they're
saying only adults can make the choice
to allow the kids
to watch this however i fairly certain
that you could go back
and and find a lot of similarly
racist or whatever you want to call it
stuff from many other
disney movies and it's all based on
stereotypes and everything else i mean
even moana i watch moana with my uh with
my niece
i mean it's all about the the pacific
islands over there and and the culture
which is actually wonderful
um but you know it's the it's the french
islands right the french basically have
invaded the islands they didn't address
that
appropriately in the movie i mean
somebody want to talk about that like we
better
you know do something about something
anyway i think i think you get my point
on this one
can you tell i'm a little exasperated
today by the endless stupidity
columbia university guys it was once a
highly esteemed
place of higher learning i used to live
on the upper west of new york city so i
was surrounded i lived mostly in the
west 80s
and columbia is in like the what is it
the upper 90s low
low low hundreds so a lot of columbia
students and i had roommates that were
i often rented i had a second uh
apartment and one of the ways that i was
able to get by was renting that
second room to to different college
students i had a chinese exchange
student live with me had all sorts of
interesting
uh young people live with me over the
years and uh colombia
which again was a place of higher
learning and a respected place and
thought of is really one of the best
places to learn a true
liberal education in america well guess
what they're doing people
they're gonna have segregated graduation
ceremonies that's right we've got a
quote here from the college fix
columbia university is offering virtual
ceremonies for native american
lgbtqia asian
latinx black and first generation and or
low-income students
over the last week of april described as
multicultural
graduation ceremonies students must
register by march 21st to get their
multicultural graduation gift
such as stalls tassels and pins and by
march
31st to be listed as participants uh
just to break it down for you a little
further so you've got your native
graduation you've got your lavender
graduation that's the lgbtq
i don't even know what the ia plus stand
for you've got
asian you've got fli that's first
generation
and or low income that seems mildly
offensive a lot of first generation
people
actually do quite well in america that's
one of the things we've got here upward
mobility i know they're trying to
destroy that
then you've got latinx which no latino
person uses the phrase latinx it's only
a bunch of
woke liberal lefty racists pretty much
and then black graduation because i
remember correctly
there was this guy martin luther king jr
and what he said was he wanted his
children
uh to be judged by the color of their
skin and that they should have separate
graduations from the white people
that's a lesser known quote that he was
putting out over the years uh just to be
very clear
they are doing a regular graduation
where everybody can be and i get it
people are gonna say but what's the
what's so wrong about this and you know
what these groups can all decide to do
what they want but this obsession with
this stuff
is anti-american it actually is
anti-american it's against
the melting pot so congratulations if
you're
bisexual you don't need a separate
graduation
you don't you don't that's wonderful
you're bisexual and you
graduated columbia university you don't
need a separate graduation
just like the asians don't need a
separate graduation the latinx don't the
black don't
and the uh what was it again the first
generation
and or low-income people they don't need
a separate
graduation either what we are doing is
whittling
our diff we've whittled away so many of
our actual differences because we've
given so many people
here freedom that we are becoming
obsessed with the tiniest differences
that we have and we are staring at those
differences and thinking that that is
the biggest thing in the room instead of
looking up and going man
we got it good in this country and you
know just to be clear about this
the every liberal institution is going
to be destroyed by this stuff i i've
really come to believe that there will
be no liberal institution that will
survive this every university
will be destroyed by this every um
every business that allows this in will
be destroyed by it like it's coming for
everything and i think the only thing
that you can do as a free person is get
your kids out of these schools
certainly get them out of public schools
but get them out of a lot of these
private schools too
build different businesses start hiring
people who are more in line with your
way of thinking because this is bad
stuff and
they're because they're going to take
those ideas they're going to take those
ideas
and they're going to bring them into the
workforce and then at work
and then at work you're going to have
you know people go to the commissary at
google
where everyone's supposed to sit and
enjoy lunch and they give you a pretty
good lunch at google i was
once invited to youtube the office is up
in northern cali i'm sure i'll never be
invited back but i was once invited and
they have a very extensive lunch
program over there but soon enough what
will happen because of this because of
putting such primacy on these immutable
characteristics
actually low income though that's very
mutable at least in america
but by putting primacy on these
characteristics then you're gonna have
all of these giant companies people
adults that are workers at lunch are
going to be saying okay
let's have the black table let's have
the low income table the asian table
and the bisexual table and then what do
you do if you got a bisexual
low income half asian then i guess
they'll have their own table
and it will just whittle away and
destroy sort of
any company's ability to do anything
kind of
kind of right and that's depressing
let's talk about this uh fouchy guy the
infallible fouchy
so look we're now basically a year
almost to the day now it's like two or
three days away i think from from the
lockdowns
from two weeks to flatten the curve and
again as i always say we all did it
we all did it we all went to the grocery
with gloves on with masks on came home
washed our paper bags and all of the
rest of that stuff
and then suddenly the phrase two weeks
to flatten the curve and just the phrase
flattened the curve
and the idea of two weeks all these
things just disappeared and now it's a
year later and
you know we're slowly opening up and
we've all kind of realized it's all just
a bunch of [ __ ] and that the people
that were you know telling us to follow
the science
we're kind of making it up all along the
way and our our ridiculous governor
gavin newsom
uh just this morning gabe gave a big
talk
and he said that now now that we're sort
of at the tail end of
covid uh which he's wrapping up he's
wrapping up all his lockdowns because he
knows the the recall is coming
and and guess what gavin the recall is
coming and it's going to happen and i'm
absolutely thrilled that it's going to
happen and i'm going to push it and push
it and push it and i hope you go away
and are banned
to the to the netherworld um but he
actually said now that now that covet is
wrapping up in effect he said well now
we can really work
on instead of going back to normal we
can go back to a more equitable world
so they're already they've used the
lockdowns they have used all of this
the the way we did the story yesterday
the way that the the teachers union here
in la doesn't want to go back to work
and they want new curriculum
curriculum put in place and all of these
things like we've seen just like so much
of the absolute craziness but fauci
who has told us to wear masks and not
wear masks and a time said he had to
kind of lie to get us to do things and
everything else
well he was on cnn uh and well
just take a look and you tell me if you
think something is rotten
in sting town you know from the buying
administration that they say
it will make its decisions based on
science what's the science
behind not saying it's safe for people
who have been vaccinated
received two doses to travel
you know that's a very good question
john and and the cdc
is carefully heading in that direction
uh
you know when we when when dr walensky
made the announcement
a day or two ago about the fact that
when you have a couple of people two or
three or more people in a family setting
both of whom are vaccinated even if it's
someone from another a friend that
doesn't have to be a member of the
family
that was the first in a multi-step
process
that they are going to be rolling out
they're being careful
understandably they want to get science
they want to get data
and then when you don't have the data
and you don't have the actual evidence
then you've got to make a judgment call
did you catch the last part of that when
you don't have the data and you don't
have the evidence then you have to make
a judgment call
so he's admitting that they don't have
the data
and they don't have the evidence well
fauci
i know you get over a 400 000 uh salary
from the government you're the highest
paid person in government and i have no
doubt that you have investments in all
sorts of companies that made a lot of
money during this whole thing
and you became a big star and all of
this stuff um but maybe you owe
some people who were out of jobs and
whose families and lives you destroyed
maybe
you owe them an apology i mean they're
basically telling you
we're going to do stuff without evidence
and then we'll figure it out later
this is not acceptable anymore this is
not acceptable
i i'm not going to pay attention to you
anymore i know
i know i'm a radical right-wing freedom
extremist
i get it but you don't deserve our
attention anymore like
uh well we don't really have the
evidence so we're going to figure out
something and then
we'll get back to the evidence thing but
i thought we were following the science
isn't that a big thing with you people
follow the science milestone
okay uh let's talk about the racists
over at msnbc
uh because i saw this clip this morning
and this is why we're doing the fifth
story because we're only doing four
today but then i saw this clip and i was
like this is just such the perfect
example
of of how the anti-racists the people
who call everyone else racist
who purport to be the most anti-racist
people how
it actually they're the most racist now
i want to preface this by saying that
you should not watch msnbc there's
nothing good happening on msnbc if you
want to be
blue pilled and you want to be part of
blue and on then you you should watch
msnbc but there's nothing honest coming
out of msnbc
and it's basically just a like a
democrat
talking point forum in essence so joy
reid is one of the
uh one of the hosts over there she's
written a lot of homophobic things in
the past
then she pretended that her email got
hacked she's no good
anyway she's uh well just listen to the
line and you tell me if this strikes you
as racist or not i want you to listen to
south dakota's senator john thune
this was his take on the minimum wage
over the weekend
the minimum wage is something that is
particularly troubling and harmful at a
time
when you're trying to get people back to
work i worked for
less than the minimum wage i worked for
the minimum wage i started busing tables
at a
dollar an hour i went up to two and a
quarter when they
moved me up in the in the place and then
i finally made it to cook
which was big time that was six bucks an
hour
what you're essentially telling those
businesses in south dakota that i just
mentioned
that you're going to increase the amount
of money that they have to pay
their workers by over 50 percent
50 percent increase you got to love the
uh tim scott standing there to provide
the patina of diversity over that uh
round of words that uh basket full of
words what do you make of john thune's
argument because
his six dollars an hour um would be 20
an hour now
if you account for inflation but your
thoughts
well he's just so out of touch did you
catch it there guys it's not what she's
saying about
john thune and minimum wage and by the
way i stand by everything that he said
there it was all very honest and and
real and
not every job is worth x amount of
dollars just because the government says
though but that's not the point
she talks about the patina of diversity
the patina of diversity because did you
catch it
did you catch it there was a black man
standing behind him he's a senator he's
a republican senator his name
is tim scott he's a good man i like him
a lot if he was running for president
i'd probably vote for him without
without any qualms
um but what she's saying is it's a
patina
of diversity now patina is a form of
corrosion
usually on a knife or a gun some sort of
metal thing when they start getting
corroded we've all
we've all been through this i've
actually got some scissors that i used
to to clip some of our vegetables that
were soaking in vinegar right now to get
rid of that corrosion
so that's a little life tip for you a
little life hack for you
um but what she's saying is in essence
these people
these white people are all racists and
that guy
back there he's the patina he's the
corrosion on this thing
right like he's that that somehow makes
it a little more palatable
the analogy's not even quite right i
don't think she's even using the
the word quite right there um but the
point is that she's in essence saying
that's the uncle tom that's the sellout
and that's the black man who is the
worst of all things because he doesn't
think the things
that i believe now i think joy reid is
an idiot and i think she has all the
wrong ideas but it has nothing to do
with her skin color it's just that she
has all the wrong
ideas and she's completely swallowed
identity politics and critical race
theory and gotten drunken on being i
guess some sort of host on television or
whatever it might be
but do you see how she is the type of
person
who will make everything about race she
will tell you she's an
anti-race right of course she's an
anti-racist
but who acted as the racist there who's
judging
the senator by the color of his skin
otherwise why mention him there right
there was a white guy on the other
shoulder behind john thune wasn't there
so it's like why did you bring up the
race of one of the guys there because
you
don't like black people who think
differently
than you think they're allowed to think
and
i know this is the crazy point of the
day but i believe that anyone
is allowed to think whatever they want
regardless of their skin color sexuality
gender
or any of those characteristics so joy
reid you're not a very good person but i
i hope that i hope that you heard this
and maybe
you'll make amends you could issue an
apology and you know we'll we'll see
what happens
um you know i've been a little dour
today i was a little
more dour than usual i don't know what
happened there the stories
you know what it is you get on twitter
in the morning you see all the craziness
we go through the stories and i was just
like oh
disney this one it's just like a punch
in the gut and somebody's going after my
friend andy no and then someone gets
canceled board and then does the worst
thing i think that was the one
that got me that when you when you still
see these people with these fake
apologies i'm just like
oh like i'm so in this fight and i see
those things like the
the guy the host of the bachelor who
issued that fake apology and it's like
man if you guys want to live on your
knees forever but you got to get out of
my way because we got a world to fix and
i know you guys are
in it with me listen guys uh our part
two
of uh my dana perino interview just went
up on youtube this morning so you can
check that out and of course the
uh full interview is up at
reubenreport.locals.com absolutely
ad free and we're going to do a little
friday panel this friday
uh on health in a time of covid because
you know now it's coming out that there
are so many studies
following science that prove that
basically the number one marker of
people that were dying of covid
had something to do with being obese it
had something to do
with body mass okay so we're going to
talk about health and little ways that
you can make yourself a little healthier
uh we're gonna have max lugovir who's
been on the show uh gina florio and
we're gonna add one other panelist who
we're working on
at the moment i think we're gonna do a q
a tomorrow what do you think
q a tomorrow i got the thumbs up q a
tomorrow
uh and if you want to play along with me
throughout the day for some live
chatting and some more
food pictures and all sorts of good
stuff related to animals and things that
are less political
join me at reubenreport.locals.com i
hope you enjoy the show i'll be back to
my normal self tomorrow
i feel like i need to like maybe i need
to like punch somebody you know what
we'll deal with
i'll deal with this in just a second
okay guys see you tomorrow